babbels flughafen meine lieben freunde
heute ist dienstag das heißt er
beschützte youtuber der kompletten
milchstraße lädt das bestürzende format
des ganzen planeten namens said tuesday
heute übrigens im sitzen weil ich bin
extrem faul war allerdings direkt an mit
dem ersten takt ob video das ist von
meinem absoluten lieblings user
hochgeladen worden
[Musik]
die fresse du glauben kann was geht was
hast du gemacht
ich war in china und ich hab dir sogar
was mitgebracht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
b
ben story ladies and gentlemen danke dir
danke für dein tutorial für einen
backflip eigentlich kann ich die scheiße
jetzt aber wieder abnehmen
das hat kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie können abends immer im bett schauen
wir was an und schweiß so gefühlt mein
handy einfach durch die gegend wenn ich
darüber lachen
[Musik]
judith s
wels
[Musik]
ja heftig doch videos machen und relativ
staffel 4
das war die beste innovation
was ich hier gesehen habe
[Musik]
man muss überlegen das ist einfach so
ein milchaufschäumer den sie einfach
genommen hat auch die andere seite dann
hingestellt hat das singen da oben
gedreht und warum lacht warum finde ich
so was so extrem witzig
[Musik]
einfachster bei service und real life
alles klar liga alles klar
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
vol live ich glaube dass echte tik tok
hält sich ein bisschen anders sein aber
das wird mir bei instagram zugeschickt
mit dem ton von sandra wie dieser vodka
for life und die wahrheit
er steckt sie jetzt das in den usb stick
in der hand
da guck
wow
also wirklich nicht gesehen dass es ein
ein fahrbarer usb stick war den nächsten
tik tok geht's auf jeden fall darum dass
da ein paar jungs ihren jungs abend hat
man dann haben sie sich so lustige
spiele ausgedacht und warten die zwei
verschiedene stapel von bechern und
haben versucht von dem ein stapel einen
becher durchdrehen und raus pusten in
den anderen stapel rhein zu fliegen
lassen
das war die dümmste erklärung aller
zeiten aber seht einfach selbst
ich habe mir das angeschaut und bin dann
nach oben die küche gegangen habe mir
selber drei becher geholt die sind alle
drei die gleichen zwei sind von red bull
und einer vom bootshaus üben das ist
sogar die beschissene überleitung aller
zeiten ich werde hierfür jetzt nicht
bezahlt oder sonst irgendwas hab ich
schreib trotzdem mal aus sicherheit
werbung hier hin weil deutschland falls
ihr das bootshaus nicht kennen sollte
das nicht irgendwie ein haus mit boten
dritt oder so sondern das ist ein extrem
geiler klub hier in köln
mein absoluter lieblingsklub auf der
kompletten welt und ich kenne die leute
die den laden betreiben und der laden
ist das ist einfach geil und euch die
schon mal daran wissen dass es so der
club ist so egal ob du mit jogginghose
an hass oder keine ahnung was du kommst
rein du kannst einfach feiern so sollte
man hat immer einen coolen abend und
gerade läuft auf jeden fall dass dj club
ranking dabei geht es ganz einfach darum
dass man auf der website abstimmen kann
welchen klub man selbst am allerbesten
von allen klubs auf der welt findet und
dann geben da manche leute irgendwie an
haye der club auf ibiza school oder der
club da wo ich in london war hammer aber
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
dafür bootshaus cologne abstimmen würde
einen link dazu unten in der
beschreibung geht dort gerne drauf er
den gefallen tun wollen wird würdet
seinen sprachenlernen babbel ist
kostenlos ich probiere es jetzt aber mit
den bechern hier also ich persönlich als
witziger gefunden der ball daneben
gefallen wäre aber ich habe auch einen
komischen humor
[Musik]
ich frag mich an der stelle jetzt gar
nichts mehr das ganze hat die diese
musik zu wecken
schreibt man in die kommentare wenn ihr
einkommen los sein
[Musik]
eine reaktion ist immer gleich ich lache
ich schaue mir das an
und ich mag einfach nicht einfach aber
ich bin doch hier in spiegel und alles
was von gott
[Musik]
ich wieder aufersteht
ja da muss ich wirklich einfach der
gesichtsfalten raushauen und wirst du
wirklich audi gesicht palma rausholen
muss
ich könnte ja mal wieder in die
kommentare schreiben wir auf die ich
heute schon geklatscht habe machen
allerdings weiter mit dem nächsten tik
tok video wo man sich im ersten moment
eventuell denkt wo auch der hat sich
einen eigenen flaschenzug gebaut aber
schlussendlich schaut einfach selbst
was bist du für ein clown ist ja klar
bin ich mein gott so erbost sprachen
lernen
er hat sich das ding doch gesehen habe
habe ich mir gedacht wow
wieder mal zehn sekunden lebenszeit
verschwendet kommen wir nun allerdings
meine lieben freunde heute auch wieder
zu meinem tik tok der woche und zwar ist
es von dem user sagt keys vc also folgt
ihm auf jeden fall aber sei klar ist
diese haben war das quiz rallye
sichtlich
[Musik]